et vous prenez tous vous prenez chacun
une bonne d'oignon est une belle et si
l'aspect que tu fais quoi là tu vas pas
te pètes éclate maintenant à tu fais
chier et à moi ça s'il te plaît j'ai pas
envie de parler avec toi vas chercher
tab est commun s'il te plaît est à moi
ça s'il te plait je pense franchement
j'avais je suis du coup tous les matins
quand je ma mère j'ai chroniqué s'arrête
aussi de creuser
ça va pas penser à 2017 se passe quoi la
page et patines tous elle n'y a rien si
c'est bon j'ai pas fait je crois pas un
peu trop que c'est la côte et à raviolis
la 3c pour les commandes et c'est tout à
fait moi qui coûta cher
sais tu lui en tirer un nouvel arrivant
la l1 3-1 petite salle au jeu des
menaces à qui la faute
[Musique]
et qui aujourd'hui pas sans toi